this is an unnecessarily rushed
explanation of the most important game
of all time Super Mario Brothers this
game jumped game design ahead like five
or ten years in one fell swoop it is
crazy all the amount of different things
that Super Mario Brothers actually did
all at the same time nailing everything
perfectly for example you have the
graphics which were absolutely beautiful
instead of a black screen most games
took place on a big black screen with
Super Mario Brothers is all about oh we
have to have a blue sky it's got to be
much more interesting if there's a blue
sky totally nailed that part the the
rest of everything was absolutely
incredible as well I mean you know so
you have the music of Super Mario
Brothers now they didn't just have the
the composer write a piece of music and
drop it into the game no no no no no
koji kondo the composer of Super Mario
Brothers worked with Shigeru Miyamoto to
find musical tracks that would perfectly
complement the speed and the tempo of
the action of the game so they put a
piece of music in the game they play the
game if it didn't work they'd throw it
out get another piece of music and they
keep doing this in doing this and doing
this until they had a piece of music
where would he play the video game and
listen to the music at the same time
they would play perfectly all together
um and also even down to the jumping of
Mario like the little noise point that
he makes many jumps I mean they made
sure that that noise worked really
really well along with the music that
you were listening to so it's almost
like you were helping to play the music
every time you jump you added a little
bit of a sound effect you look at jazz
improvisation kind of thing to the music
the level design was absolutely
incredible I mean Miyamoto had this way
of designing levels in Super Mario
Brothers that would basically let you
think that you were you know discovering
all these hidden secrets even though he
had left all the hidden secrets in the
perfect place for you to accidentally
discover them to think that you were a
genius the first five seconds of Super
Mario Brothers are absolutely an amazing
piece of game design where you know
there's a super mushroom that it turns
you big but he puts the pipe right there
so you hit the pipe in that the others
we hit the mushroom and the mushroom
comes out over the bricks runs into the
pipe and then bounces off of the pipe in
the mouse's into you it's almost
impossible to avoid getting hit by that
mushroom you want to get hit by that
mushroom mushroom is good so it
eliminates the chance that a player
doesn't hit the mushroom it's like a
tutorial it teaches you how to play the
game um she Super Mario Brothers my
goodness I mean you know just the fact
that
all of these things all came together
all at the same time the the grant the
gameplay is so fantastic it's amazingly
perfectly tweaked mario has this
incredible momentum the way that the
game scrolls everything was just done so
well that it basically just it just
skyrocketed videogames and it just
started laying down a guidebook for this
is how video games are designed and and
generations of game designers would look
at it and and just read from Super Mario
Brothers how to make a video